Wind.
In my ear.
Windy.
Let's see this.
I'm getting trauma.
My trauma.
Welcome.
We don't use the three word around here.
oh my gosh oh did you guys watch gamescom uh that was this week it was the other day right um I caught I don't remember when I came in it was Joffrey saying something that I was like wow what a lot oh I came in when Joffrey was like he was like that's right I can like I came in,
I opened the stream at this line.
He was like, I can say that Hollow Knight will come out, or Silk Song will come out this year!
That he's, like, as soon as I opened up the stream, that's what he said.
And I was like, whoa!
Lana, thank you so much for the redirect.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Welcome, welcome!
Yeah, but, um...
Yeah, well, why?
Oh, I was talking about Gamescom because There was one point when they were like This game people have been waiting For so long For so long And people in the chat were like Half-Life, Half-Life 3 Half-Life 3, Half-Life 3 And And it was that Warhammer game I was like No way can you imagine if Half-Life 3 ever got announced while I'm playing the series.
That would be insane.
But wouldn't be the first time.
I'm pretty good luck when it comes to that kind of stuff, maybe.
But yeah, I watched Gamescom.
I thought it was very funny that the only time the chat...
I don't usually, like, look at the chat because they're always, like...
You know, they're just, like, a bunch of 10-year-olds that are...
are really that are really annoying but the chat united for one single game there was one game that that the whole chat was just like win win ww yes it's peak it's peak yes yes based uh whatever yes horrid professor guessed it lego batman it was like seeing world peace It was amazing.
Everybody united for Lego Batman.
I was shocked.
And then.
And then I got a fan edit on TikTok of Lego Batman.
And, um, that game is kind of BL.
So I kind of want to play it now.
talks to the Joker and he's just like there is no us and then the Joker cries and then Batman later on is just like help me fix us and I'm like whoa whoa yeah
he says I don't do ships he says that that is the movie wait there's a Lego Batman movie okay now I want to watch the movie and play
It's so funny that, like, overall...
Bald, thank you!
Today is my birthday!
That's not important, Silk Song!
Happy birthday, Bald!
But it's so funny that, like, pretty much the Lego games are so highly regarded.
Like, why?
Why?
That's a Lego Batman movie, but Lego Batman 2 is Batman Super Batman BL!
What is this?
Wait until you get to the part where Batman and Joker play basketball together.
Ooh, la la.
Silk Song isn't coming out this year.
It comes out in... Wait, two weeks?
soon?
I actually, I saw people talking about, like I saw Kiara she was like, I wish I had played it, played Halo Knight sooner.
But two weeks is crazy.
I think I saw Doki saying that she was going to play Halo Knight all next week or something.
September 4th?
Wow.
That's crazy.
Next week, I'm gonna...
So, I leave...
I go to MGSCon this weekend.
So, if some of you guys might be at MGSCon, or some of you guys might be watching MGSCon, or some of you guys might be at...
What else?
Anime, NYC.
I hope you guys have a fun weekend.
Doing...
Whatever...
With whatever you got going on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Um...
Enjoy NYC, Mint.
I...
I just said I was going to MGSCon.
Um...
That's, uh...
Other side of the country.
Yeah.
I didn't actually realize that I was on the same weekend as AMYC, so I'm glad I didn't plan anything to plan for AMIC.
But next week, next Tuesday, I can play Delta.
So I'm gonna be playing it all day, baby.
Probably start to finish in one go.
Yeah.
So I go from MGSCon straight to Delta.
I'm very, very excited.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I want to play it the whole thing all the way through yeah i'm gonna be starting early in the day and probably finishing who knows honestly
it took me a bajillion times trying to get that line at the very beginning it's stuck in your head i'm suffering from a self perpetuating cycle song stuck in the head listen to song song continues to stay stuck in the head.
Yeah, you should listen more.
More, more, more!
Also, Darth Clone, welcome back, Darko!
I did watch the Metal Gear launch trailer.
I did.
Looks so good.
Yeah, it will be an endurance stream, but like, I'll be- I'll be so full of energy.
full of energy.
Have you seen the new wild hint students in Blue Archive?
Are those the new JP girlies?
Is Kanoui the zombie looking one?
Because if so, yes.
I don't remember their names yet, though.
My baseball team is blowing chunks again.
What does that mean?
They're not good.
Is your baseball team bad?
I need some mint therapy.
Yeah, we'll play B-B-B We'll be playing a little bit of half-life, too, again today.
I don't...
I...
Ravenholm!
I know why they say don't go.
I don't want to go back.
I don't...
Since the Ghost Mead Cafe is closed, lame, on my birthday.
Sunday!
Gotta get an early happy birthday wish.
Asha!
Happy birthday!
birthday, I'm sorry.
Guys, what if I wear double glasses?
Extra smart.
Whoa!
It's giving me it.
It's giving me X-ray vision!
I can see the future!
Four ears and four eyes.
But today, I'm just normal glasses.
Six eyes.
Oh, I guess it would be six eyes.
Yeah.
Six eyes.
Hentai.
What do you mean by that?
What with my x-ray vision?
You don't want me to see your tidy whitties?
Shall we get into it?
Oh, I think we shall
I actually opened up the correct game this time.
I opened up the right game this time, so...
Let's go.
I went out of there.
This is the right one, right?
I think so.
Music.
Okay, what do I got here?
Grenade, we're on the shoddy SMG.
Revolver.
Oh, this thing?
If I press G, it comes out.
How do I use this thing again?
Oh, I think that's the blast and then this is like if I want to pick stuff up.
Yeah, yeah.
Come here, come here.
Whoa!
Oh!
Wait, I don't hear the...
Mmm soup.
Wait, is it this?
No.
How do I hear the soup?
Soup.
I don't hear it.
Is it a failure to grab?
Oh!
Mmm soup.
I'll take that.
Aww.
Mr.
Well, clearly we don't go that way.
Okay.
Soup.
Thank you.
Any info for digital pass holders and how that's gonna work?
Mint GS Con VTuber Ambassador Hostess.
What do you mean how it's gonna work?
Like.
Ugh.
For the digital tickets.
Like the stream?
Yeah.
I think there should be an email, no?
They just put out a message on Kickstarter.
Like, how do we access?
I would.
Check your email.
I don't know anything about the inner workings, I'm sorry.
But I can tell you I'll be there in the morning.
I'll be there a little bit after it will.
On stream, I have a thing in the morning.
And if all goes well, I'll be in 3D, which is kind of fun.
And then...
I'll be doing a little something with Miss Cynthia later.
Not to just spoil everything, but in case you wanted to know if you wanted to know what to watch, to see me.
Sorry, I'm eating a cough drop.
And then I will be doing a little bit of karaoke.
Just to kind of start it off at the very end.
So...
That should be everything.
I just got the mail about how it's going to work.
There you go.
Yeah, everyone who got a virtual pass for MGSCon, please check.
No!
Check your e-brill.
Oh, waste and bullets.
Still feels loud, but I'll adjust audio as I go along.
Sorry, guys.
Oh, that's right.
Um...
What is that?
Also, why don't I remember how to smash these?
Oh, wait, I do.
I'm silly.
Sorry.
It's like, what do I use to smash?
I remember.
Um, what is that?
Oh, it's coming from up there.
Can I see it?
Is there a way to climb?
time?
I don't see anything up there.
Walk into it and find out.
Am I gonna get jump scared?
I'm scared because we're still not out of Ravenholm.
Oh, there he is!
Can he see me?
Is it a sniper?
I thought it was a turret at first, but... What have
you You could tell yourself when you first played MGS3.
I know, right?
I'm trying not to freak out about it.
Because I'm trying to be normal.
They did give me grenades, huh?
Oops.
Uh, okay, hold on.
I'm a little heavy-handed.
Thank you.
Is that our guy?
Hmm.
Nice.
I want his gun.
That's what I want.
First try, absolutely.
These are dead, right?
What the?
The crates were jiggling a little bit.
Where is he?
Oh!
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
Howie!
Oh,
luckily those...
Oh, wait, there is supplies!
Hi!
Hey!
Oh my gosh.
This is messed up!
Oh my god.
Do I need to go when he shoots?
It seems like he takes a second to re- Okay, so he has three shots?
Four?
Three?
No, five.
Because there was two over there.
And then I ran over here.
I believe.
Okay, maybe he just gives up after a second.
Maybe it's not like he has to reload.
Hey, chill, chill.
Okay.
Alright, um, let's see.
Uh...
I'm running.
How close am I?
Oh my gosh.
The thing's gonna fall on me.
I'm gonna get crushed.
Holy!
That's not fair.
This is unfair.
This is, that's not fair.
Okay.
What is he getting?
Alright.
Oh my gosh, ouch!
I was still crouch.
Chill, chill.
It's just a box!
Chill, chill!
Oh my gosh.
Try turning your PC clock a week ahead.
I wonder how that will work for...
Oh my god!
Where did that thing come from?
He almost saved me, actually.
I wonder how that will work in Delta though.
If I turn my PC clock up to a week ahead.
Alright.
Iki-mas!
No!
I missed.
Dang it.
Hut!
Yeah, I got him.
We got it eventually.
Is there any point actually exploring around here now that I think about it?
Full ammo.
Hold on.
Were there any more grenades that I left?
Did I pick up everything?
Let's check.
I'm backtracking like crazy.
Okay, never mind.
Okay.
That's fine.
I just want to get out of here, man.
I don't want to be in this chapter anymore.
Wait, does this open?
I don't want to be here.
It sounds so scary!
Physics are happening.
I can't even get on this.
I have to go under.
Use the grab gun.
Oh, true!
But on what?
To get up there?
Oh, wait a second.
Oh!
Sorry, buddy.
There's a little bit of supplies.
It pays to explore.
It really does.
Okay.
And there's more grenades here for the future.
More grenades for the future.
What was that?
What did I just grab?
Whatever
that was.
Oh.
I don't want to live well.
Sorry.
Wait, there's another guy.
Another guy?
What did I...
Whoa!
Wait, one second.
I'm actually gonna...
Scoop myself down, make myself a little bit smaller.
That should be good.
Whoa, whoa!
Woo!
I got some fancy stuff here.
Okay.
What is this?
Well, whatever would be here, they would have taken it out, right?
Surely there's nothing left?
Gosh, I'm so paranoid.
I'm absolutely paranoid.
I camped and I'm proud.
I don't care.
What is this?
Oh, more...
so
do I like go over this
do I like stack this up and go oh wait there's a ladder
I see it I saw it before you guys before I saw your comments okay to be fair
well you can't tell me to use the grab gun more and then like and then i try to what's that is that a chicken oh it's a bird wait it really was a bird that bird's about to die isn't it okay now i save
i want to go home i wish to leave
oh my gosh oh you you're still alive!
Wait!
How are you still alive?
How do I use this thing?
Why does it feel so weak?
Well, I guess I was far away, but...
Does this weapon have alt-fire?
It does, but I have zero.
I'm just gonna...
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Why are they so smart?
Where are you shooting me from?
I don't play Call of Duty, please!
I guess I have to go in there, but...
Okay, hold on.
What was that gun again?
Which...
Overwatch...
standard-issue pulse rifle.
I'm sneaking.
I don't see anybody.
I hear them for sure.
Oh my god!
How do you see me?
How are
you?
Wait.
Okay.
I try to blow up the things but i couldn't see them once i ducked oh my god you guys okay
no sneaking in this game clearly
is there anything else over here
i'm going in i hate when i have to fight people let me just fight the zombies
I think I got him.
Those are not people?
What do you mean they're not people?
It looks like a people?
No?
It looks like a people to me.
Anything in these trucks?
Oh, whoa.
Okay, nice.
They're not people anymore?
Well then I don't feel any remorse killing them.
I don't feel bad at all.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, what's going on?
Please don't spam!
Moan?
Who's moaning and groaning?
Wait, who's my friends?
That looks like a bad guy.
Oh, those are my friends!
Winston?
It wasn't me, was it?
That's me!
We've been getting communication from Alex.
I'll see if I can reach her again.
Winston.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, he's moaning.
Can I take your stuff?
No, I have full bullets.
Okay.
One second.
Hold on, I'm getting their stuff.
It's really important.
Is Winston gonna make it?
I don't know that guy.
One moment, please.
I'm conducting important research.
Okay.
okay not that i need much hi wait am i am i am i about out it's leon we're all clear and i've got gordon freeman are we out of raven home dr freeman you're kidding hello i've been on the line with alex booty shot over here dr freeman oh my gosh the eli vebs is indispensable to the liberation
so many moaning and groaning people.
Alex, it's Leon, and I've got Gordon Freeman with me.
She just looks like she has a tummy ache.
Hi.
Gordon, you made it through Ravenholm.
I did.
Somehow.
I need your help.
They've taken my father.
Barely.
He's been taken to Nova Prospect.
The Vortigons tracked the
ship, but I think it's still easier to sneak in than to break out.
You wanted to take the coast road?
Moaning, moaning.
He won't last five minutes on foot.
It's spawning season for the ant lions.
That's why I called you.
What is it?
What's that?
That's an ant lion?
Yeah, good idea.
Hold on a sec.
Mone.
Norko?
Bring the buggy out.
Put it on the dock right now.
Gordon Freeman will be driving it.
Good timing.
Okay, Alex.
We're all right.
Good timing.
Okay, Alex.
We're all set.
Bye, Alex.
Mone, moan, moan.
Before you hit the road, you might want to grab some med kits.
Restock on ammo.
see where you're headed there's an ammo supply crate on the back of the car if that's any comfort stay with the car make use of the thumpers you'll stand a fair chance against the ant lions what's an ant lion i'll read you ahead to let the next base know you're coming boy shorepoint to nlo shorepoint to new little odessa come in odessa do you read
the map oh wait well this is out of date but you can still see more or less the route to nova
posts wait i don't know at all shortpoint to new little odessa come in odessa do you read are they dead shortpoint to nlo so where am i going shortpoint to new little odessa i'm at lighthouse point is that where i'm at and then i'm trying to get to shortpoint to nlo shortpoint to new little odessa come in odessa do you know we're at shortpoint and then we're trying to get to nlo what's that x Shorepoint to New Little Odessa.
Come in, Odessa.
Do you read?
It says you're at Shorepoint.
Shorepoint to NLO.
Yeah.
Shorepoint to New Little Odessa.
Come in, Odessa.
I don't think they're coming in.
I think they're...
Highway 17.
Hello, Dr. Freeman.
Hello.
The car's all ready for you.
What are you shooting at?
Hop in and I'll lower you down to the beach.
The beach?
Are those ant lions?
Is that an ant lion?
Whose lucky job is it to just sit here and fire all day?
The car's ready for you now, Dr. Freeman.
Is he for Zoom?
Thank you.
I forgot that this is a feature.
Oh, they do look like ants.
Okay.
Wait, what's up there?
One moment, please.
Oh, I can't get... Wait.
Can I?
No.
Okay.
I'm going in!
They can leap?
Okay.
They look like they're tight.
Good.
Here we go.
Shift turbo, space handbrake.
I'm just gonna follow the road.
You think that'll be good enough?
Or...
Don't shoot me.
Don't shoot me, please.
Oh, they look like...
They're about ready to eat me.
Oh, are you kidding me?
Wait.
Ah!
Oh my god!
Help, please!
Get that car up, right?
Get the hell out of here!
Oh, the gravity gun.
Uh.
There we go.
Okay, now I'm leaving.
Bye!
twice good thing we don't have a windshield I better not keep my mouth open though while riding this thing
um I'm going in a circle um I'm not quite sure where to go I went in a circle okay um cool I'm just getting a feel of it I do have a gun you're right I'm just getting a feel of it, you know?
Along the coast.
Holy loud!
It's so loud.
I'm gonna go this way.
Oh, here we go.
Is this a road?
Maybe not.
I'm lost again.
I'm gonna go along the coast.
Like we said the first time.
Let's not divert from the plan, you know?
Oop, oop, oop.
Uh...
Team!
No good.
Team, we're having a bad time.
Team!
Maybe I can blast my way out of here.
Um...
Team!
I could use some help here.
No kidding, we made it.
Uh, this coast.
I...
I've lost this hell.
Do I actually have a map that I could use?
Because, uh, otherwise...
Guys, this ain't looking so good.
Uh...
Oh!
Wait, I think I need the boost there.
Okay, I see.
Ah!
We're fine.
Everything's cool.
Okay.
Uh, wrong way?
Wait a second.
One moment.
One moment, please.
Yeah, we need that, though.
Gamer Paint does it again.
Um...
Yes, I apologize for my incompetence.
You're just gonna...
You're just...
I'm sure you're used to it by now, right, everyone?
Okay.
Wait a second.
What's here?
Oh.
Nothing.
I'm too fat.
But I go through here, no?
But there was also...
There was also...
Um...
I think I go through there.
Doing fine, Minky.
I think so!
I'll try this way.
Will let me in?
Oh.
I'm breaking the law.
Here we go.
Ooh, coming in hot.
Coming in hot!
Thank you.
Uh...
That wasn't me.
I like to squash them more than...
more than shoot them.
What the hell is this?
Oh.
Oh gosh.
It's not behind me either.
Can I go in here?
It's locked.
Oh, there's something in there.
Oh, stay near the thumpers.
Is this a thumper?
What is this thing?
Lacked.
Oh, look at that.
They're scared.
Whoa, interesting.
But I hear something in there.
Oh,
oh, that's really spooky.
I don't know if I like this.
Come here.
You son of a gun.
Where'd you go?
Oh, there should be several in here, aren't there?
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I see it.
Why don't you come out?
Not you!
How did you even get out?
Oh my god!
I don't... I don't like...
Okay, now I'll be brave.
That's so scary.
Holy...
Oh, that's creepy.
How do I get up there, though?
I hear them but like they're all around me and all I'm a little freaked out I think I got him oh I hear it oh my god it's so scary I don't think I can
I don't like that I don't like hearing him at all ruthless you gotta be with these things though no I
think there's one in here.
Oh no.
There we go.
Hehehe.
I can't get over the sound.
Throw a grenade in the room.
I guess we could try that.
I hear him still.
You hear that?
Try again.
Another?
Okay, I'm just gonna go in.
Oopsie.
I'm not going in.
I lied.
This
thing!
Oh my god.
Hell no.
Oh my gosh.
No wonder it was breathing like that.
Nasty.
Nasty, nasty, nasty.
Oh.
Oh, terrible.
Okay.
Let's run to the thumper.
Okay, um, I'm still lost.
I wish I had a map, for real.
Push the button.
Are you guys crazy?
Actually, hold on.
I just saved.
Let's see what happens when you do.
Do we go
this way?
Nice.
Whoa!
Sea tour!
Never mind.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Shoot.
Uh, guys.
How do I reload?
Well, they don't like water.
Yes, they do.
Gravity gun it!
Okay.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Okay, we're probably fine now.
No, we're not fine.
Oh, shoot.
Go away.
Uh.
Stop!
Now we're probably fine.
There we go.
Holy cow.
We go so fast.
Okay.
I heard...
I heard radios.
Chill!
Oh gosh.
Wait.
Go away.
Back!
Back, you beasts!
Oh, they're killing them too.
Ow!
Back!
Back, you beast.
Let's see.
How do I want to kill these guys?
Oh!
Like that.
That works.
Anything in here?
I feel like you can't trust a single place ever.
Whoa.
How do we get in there?
Oh, hey, we'll use this guy.
I'm running low on shotgun bullets.
What are they dropping?
What ammo are they even dropping here?
Oh.
What is this?
They were...
Those are my friends.
They're spying on my friends.
Why?
Oh, perverts they are.
Voyors...
Wait, G- I waited.
Where'd you see G-Man at?
The suitcase at the top of the building.
Oh, the guys that were having the meeting?
How can you guys tell when it's him or not?
Wait, why is he talking to my friends then?
That's not good, huh?
body language body language I get that sorry that's that's Ursula
okay I don't want to be down here uh oh I think I'm stuck
no I want to run Back towards you Wait, so my friends I was pointed over that way So I just gotta keep going along the coast Okay, okay
Gravity gun the tire So if you have a briefcase If I see briefcase I see G-Man
Moist More or less Okay, okay.
I'll keep that in mind.
Oh, John!
I thought I ran you over.
Ouch!
It was worth it.
Wait, they have a better car.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm
taking this stuff.
Leave me alone.
Oh my gosh, finally some health.
Wait, I feel like I'm not going to make this.
No.
Oh.
Okay, that's fine too.
Grab gun.
That's fine.
You missed me, dummy.
Can I take this?
No!
They're like, you do not have the proper license.
The authority.
Dang.
Okay, well, I took care of those guys.
Onwards.
We go.
It sucks that they just continuously spawn, otherwise I would stop by the boats and stuff, but, you know.
What's up there?
How do I get up there?
Hmm.
Okay.
We got a thing here, but there's literally nothing around.
Okay, that's cool.
Not a sightseeing tour.
Unfortunately, yeah.
Um.
Are you good?
Gordon Freeman.
That's me.
Hurry, get in the basement.
We're expecting gunships at any moment.
Gunships?
Colonel Cabbage?
We'll be glad to see you made it.
Colonel Cabbage.
One moment.
I will wait on your gunships.
Wait, how do, why don't the lions, the ant lions spawn here?
What are those?
Okay, that's exciting.
Love that.
Only on sand.
Oh, I didn't realize.
Ah!
I'd get into the basement if I were you.
We're bracing for an attack.
You scared me, mister.
Oh, hi.
Okay.
I'm just...
I'm taking your things just a little bit real quick.
What is this?
What is that for?
Some sort of alternate...
I don't know what for there's much of it which makes me concerned okay into the basement oh wait there's another shack hold on more oh no golly gee oh please this steerable rocket launcher is our best bet for taking down a gunship take that ah hello hello I'll be right with you okay where was I yes using the laser guide you can steer your rocket past the gunship's defenses and prevent it from shooting down your rocket oh anger it at first but if you can survive long enough to make several direct hits you'll be rewarded with a prize worthy of any mantelpiece now who's going to be the lucky one to carry it into combat oh yes they both look at me I couldn't have asked for a finer volunteer I did Colonel Odessa Cubbage at your service.
Ah!
Oh!
Gunship!
Let me just send a warning to Lighthouse Point, and then I'll come right up and lend a hand.
Remember, use the launcher's laser guide to steer your rockets past the gunship's defenses.
Oh!
Oh, look, they're Maddox!
Or he is.
Um...
Did I get it?
Is there a good place to go for this?
Is there a good place I can shoot you from here?
Okay.
Okay, the glass is like indestructible here.
Oh my god!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
They were giving me ammo and stuff.
That's so cute.
I'm
running right into it.
Oh,
I have no ammo.
I have ammo in here.
Thank you.
I'm stuck on the wall.
Thank you very much.
Is that it?
Defend a little Odessa from the gunship attack.
I'll take more, just in case.
No!
I just talked to him.
Yes.
I guess there's no more carrots.
They look like big old carrots, right?
I think there was some downstairs.
Are you okay?
Get going, Dr. Freeman.
We know Eli Vance is depending on you.
Okay.
Where am I going?
Wait, what's in here?
Is there stuff on the roof?
Damn indestructible window.
It would have been first try, otherwise.
If the window wasn't in distra- I had a plan, you guys.
You can't fault me for...
You know.
No one would have known...
Or no one could have known that the...
That you can't...
That you can't shoot out the window.
That's that.
I gather you've disposed of that...
gunship dr. Freeman yep your reputation sir is well deserved I shall have someone open the gate for you immediately so that you can drive on oh that says mustache dr. Vance is in great need what about it use extreme caution when approaching the bridge radio silence from that outpost leads me to believe it has come under combine control still you're clearly the right man for the job you'll make it through if anyone can farewell and please tell dr. Vance that Colonel coverage regrets not having been able to rescue him in person look at I am.
What's wrong with it?
The Freeman must now hurry on.
The Eli Vance is held in distress most dire.
Most dire.
Is there reason for delay?
You, I just heard the information.
I'm going, I'm going.
Are you okay?
Good luck in Nova Prospect, Dr. Freeman.
Thank you.
mouse game with the gunship and rockets was an accident during playtesting they saw that the gunship would treat the rocket as a target so they made it part of the core loop what
thank you
get your car doc you won't get far on foot oh you're right
oh booty shot booty shot
save okay
open the gate open the gates drive safely thank you
oh come on why does it do that to me whoa our
fallen comrade Oh!
Jeez.
Disgusting.
I'm not drunk driving!
I'm driving very normally.
Very calmly and safely.
I might hit a few men.
I missed one.
Ah!
Oh shoot.
Don't shoot me.
Oh!
Uh oh, that doesn't sound good.
Uh, that didn't sound good.
I see them over there.
I wish I had a sniper.
I'd be able to get them so easily if I had a sniper.
I could use my new...
I
thought the water was more shallow, okay?
Hmm.
Can I hit them?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
That scared the heck out of me.
me what happened there oh my god
trying to hit them i'm
trying to hit them with my gun
not doing such a great job i'm just gonna go in circles killing
men is just as important as killing creatures
Minor lacerations.
I'm going in circles again.
Oh!
Oh, I tried to get that supply box, but I didn't get it.
Yeah.
Equality!
Oh.
It's not fun having the little guys on top of you as well as these guys on top of you.
These guys are also shooting at you.
Okay.
Oh.
Uh, that's not my gun.
Oh, he's not even focusing on me.
That's nice.
Wait.
There it is.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I finally turned it on.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Somehow.
Yeah.
Yeah, we parked right next to the thumper.
Safe for now.
Don't you dare.
Oh,
that guy's dead.
I guess then we can go up.
I did save, right?
I think I did.
Did they come up here?
Or did they just stay on the sand in general?
Woo!
Eep!
Oh.
That was close.
Oh my gosh.
I saw a supply box in there.
I just need to...
I think it was?
I don't know if that got the guy.
I definitely did not.
He's fast.
I hear the other guy.
He's just going off on the...
Oh!
Oh my god!
Unfair!
There's
nobody else?
Oh, what's that?
Lucky.
Maybe?
There's nobody else?
These.
This is what I was trying to do.
You know what?
Honestly, it's a good thing I waited to grab them.
I really needed them.
Okay, nice.
Let me get my gun out.
Not the shotgun.
We'll use this one again.
But where?
Don't go carah.
Actually, I'm gonna save.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
One more.
Is it just him?
Use the crossbow.
I don't have a crossbow.
What are you talking about?
Use the thing you don't have.
Oh,
not, not, not Grenade.
No, not you either.
You.
Let's go back to this.
Oh, there's supplies down here, though.
Always appreciated.
I'll take whatever you got.
it's crazy how i guess you guys say they're not humans right they're like robots or whatever i guess that would make sense why they oh oh what am i doing
oh i made a mistake suddenly there's music wait i don't even know what i'm supposed to do
the cool music can stop you need to do that yeah but i wanted to look around to see what I need to pick up.
Maybe the car?
Oh, it's a puzzle.
Let's see.
Moment?
Okay, so I can't even get up there.
Or, oh, wait.
Is the goal to lower this?
I like how people are just like...
Move the crane around.
Yeah, with my eyes first.
Thank you.
It's called a little thing called patience.
You know, you might not have it, but uh...
Did that just open up?
Oh, hell no.
Oh hell no!
No, wait!
Oh, it's swinging too much!
Ah!
Oh, now they're all the way over there.
I don't know, I don't control this thing.
I'm trying to smush them.
And drop.
Did I get them?
Oh, no, it surely did not.
Uh, good thing they have stormtrooper aim.
Why won't it lift anymore?
Eh?
I can't get it to lift it.
I don't know how to pull up.
That's an issue.
Oh, it's down.
Okay, okay.
Kill three enemies using the crane.
Oh.
Yeah, good enough.
Anyway.
Questing back up.
Is that what you have?
No other guys?
So far?
Yeah, backseaters are going crazy.
But it's okay.
I'm still having fun.
I'm just ignoring people.
Minto loves the vehicle environment.
Killstoret.
Yes.
It's my first time playing, so you know, probably won't see everything immediately first time.
Just how it is.
If we fall down there, it's sudden death.
I'm trying to see if this is open or not.
Nope, okay.
Alright.
Okie dokie.
I'm gonna switch to my shotgun Because it seems like we might be getting nice and close and personal with these fellas In here
Do I need my car?
Do I need to Oh wait a second
Oh gosh Oh gosh Once I Once I If I pull this, I'm afraid of what will happen.
No calling for backup.
Maybe.
Oh, it opened this.
Okay.
Hello?
She was saying hello back?
Where?
What?
Kind of, there we go.
Oh, that didn't work at all.
Okay.
I love explodey barrels.
It was a flare.
Oh, no.
Were they calling more people?
Nasty.
Nasty work.
How many of you are in there?
One.
Wait, are you a friend?
No.
I don't think that worked.
That's okay.
Ah!
I think I need to drive my car up there, huh?
Oh.
I need to drive my car up through there, huh?
Okay, interesting.
Ding, ding, ding!
Ah, ha, ha, ha, ha.
I've learned your ways, game.
I've learned your ways.
Can I get up top here?
Soup.
I just always want to climb.
Wait a second.
Here, here, here.
Look.
But there's nothing even here.
So lame.
There's something on top.
What's the point of being able to climb?
I guess they're just like, if you want a gravity gun, everybody here's a bunch of fun things for your pleasure okay let's go get my car wait a second no i'm silly before we do that let's go clear let's go make sure this area over here is clear which i have a feeling it is not i have an inkling of a feeling Or?
Maybe I did.
Hello?
Maybe I was wrong.
It's quiet.
Only ghosts.
Me.
Yeah, I'm definitely here.
Only me.
Please do not block me.
No, it's like, Lays.
Do not block front of building.
All right, all right.
Let's go get my car.
I'm really glad that the guys in this game don't, like, have patrols.
You know, like, with Metal Gear, they're just like, okay, my patrol's over.
Time to swap out with a new group of people.
It's not an inkling.
It's a minkling.
Okay, I need to put my car...
What the heck was that?
I need to put it, like, right here.
This isn't really a stealth game.
Yeah, I wish they just...
I don't want to be perceived.
Oh, I was like, where'd the ladder go?
Okay, car!
Tract arm.
Meow.
It's not really...
It doesn't really feel like Gordon's.
style, though, huh?
To be sneaky.
It doesn't seem like the type.
I hope this goes better than when I did the crane games for those Metal Gear mugs.
I get so much I couldn't tell.
Okay, that should be good.
Oh, Are you okay?
What's all that like?
It's a lot of creaking and cracking.
I think it needs to be over a little bit.
Easy.
How dare you doubt my strategy?
Nice toss.
Thank you.
All right.
How dare you doubt my...
Wait, I could have just put it over there.
Oh, maybe I should have.
Oops.
Okay, anyway.
I wanted to go over the bridge!
Oh, Jesus.
Does it fit?
Or is it me?
Okay.
One more time.
No, come back up.
Oh, don't swing.
Don't swing, please.
Don't swing.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm forklift certified right now.
I feel like I should get my I feel like I've earned something.
Crane lift certified.
Why do I get stuck here?
That's probably what happened.
Oh my gosh.
I saw the blue on that thing, and I thought it was a person running at me.
Oh.
Let's go!
My car is probably...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I missed.
Um.
Ah!
Oh, my gosh.
I was.
Do I need to get out and fight this thing?
Na-na-na-na-na-na-da-na.
Oh, no.
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Uh.
This.
Oh my gosh, he shoots me down.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Oh, wait, the sand guys can get me here.
No?
No, they can't.
Uh.
Rockets in the van.
Ow!
Ows!
Ows, ows, ows, ows, ows!
This is really evil.
Having no sprint here is really bad.
Oh, please, please.
In the van.
Oh, I see it.
Um, can I get them, please?
Can you...
Please, let me open the van, please!
How do I get in there?
Oh, there's a side door.
Oh my gosh.
Open up!
Help!
Please!
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Ah!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I miss having my guys.
I miss having them.
I miss having the guys.
Wait, there's more here too.
Stop shooting down my stuff!
That was a close one, honestly.
Too close.
Am I supposed to get these out of the way now?
Get out of my way.
Soup.
Out of my way.
You gotta juke his shot.
Yeah, I was in a bit of a panic.
I hope there's nobody down there.
I'm just littering.
That's fine.
We're putting car batteries in the...
In the ocean.
Yeah, car batteries in the ocean!
I was trying.
to get this thing like the big van to move but clearly i'm trying to see now if there's any more health underneath doesn't seem like it okay car battery is in the ocean nothing else okay
oh come wait there's got to be stuff in here oh Yeah, baby.
That works.
Uh, let me in.
Let me in.
There we go.
Oh, I didn't realize it was health.
Yay!
The leeches are all that's left in the ocean.
Don't say that.
Oh, wow.
My blood.
I've marked this place.
Minto got into the strange van.
It's mine.
That's my van.
Oh boy!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Thing!
What the hell is that?
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Uh...
I don't know what these are.
Are you hearing something?
Huh?
Ah!
Ouch!
Oh!
Out of my way!
Brute forcing it a little bit.
Ouch, ouch!
Oh my gosh, these things sucks.
I've learned my lesson.
Oh no!
No, please!
No!
Mufasa, please!
Mufasa!
No, no, no, no.
Don't come towards me!
And a little butt tag.
Oh my god, he's hanging on my friend.
He doesn't want to let go!
Final fracture detected.
Oh, we got it.
I think?
I need to like...
Um...
Things could be better.
Things could be way better right now.
Gordon's silly road trip.
Yeah.
Oh...
Okay.
Yes!
But there's all this right here.
Where'd that thing go?
Nobody does it like you, boss.
Wait,
is it too big for me to pick up?
Maybe I can roll over it.
Have a look next to the rock on the hill?
Oh!
Oh, I didn't mean to use it.
Shoot.
I thought I pressed...
I thought I pressed one.
Oh, there's a guy.
Oh, he's running.
I think I can get him.
Dang.
Oh, he still caught him.
That's insane.
Uh, Lydia!
Thank you so much for the...
Redirect!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
I like sniping.
Lead your shots as if I didn't just give both guys.
Good.
Root force wins again.
What is that, though?
What is that?
Is that like a force field?
It's a gate.
Hold on, I'm gonna go close.
Can I go through?
Oh.
Are there any other guys?
Wait!
God.
Whoa!
I pinned him to the wall!
Pin a soldier to the boomboard.
I got an achievement for it.
That's crazy.
Oh, okay.
So I can go through, but I don't think my car can probably go through.
So what we're going to do is we're going to get it nice and close.
We're going to get it nice and close just in case we start getting, you know, bush or something.
I don't know what's gonna happen here.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
Nice and close.
Hokey-dokey.
Yeah, I guess that was, yeah, it's like a crossbow that's...
I heard somebody.
I walked over that and I heard that, but I definitely heard like a radio sound.
I think.
I guess I did.
You bastard.
I don't want to waste all of it though.
Holy moly.
Okay.
What is...
Oh my gosh, I was just about to say what is that?
No!
Oh my god, they are...
are evil.
The balls.
But they can be destroyed.
Oh!
They can be destroyed, right?
Pick them up.
Can I?
Soup.
Only by water.
Like that.
I like how they're charging their car.
Nice.
Why am I picking up yet?
Oh.
What's this?
Thank you.
And health.
Somewhere?
There was...
There were two balls.
Where could the other one be?
Another ball.
Other ball.
The way they growl.
Okay.
Very good.
Nothing in the truck?
Lamb.
Explosives.
Danger.
Okay.
I see that...
Oh, I thought I saw something behind there.
Oh!
Lucky.
Um...
I see that the gate is powered by the car, by the way.
I'm just looking around.
Do I, like, blow it up?
More?
I saw you.
Steal their Wi-Fi.
I'm hacking their databases.
That
felt good.
That felt good.
Forgot the parking break.
Rookie mistake.
All right.
That wasn't so bad.
Okay, crossbows under four.
Oh!
Sorry.
What about how much ammo do I have?
Oh, not so much.
It will be used in dire situations.
Okay, through the tunnel of loading the next scene.
Oh gosh.
Oh, uh, I can't see.
I...
Oh, no, no, no.
Uh, thought that there might be things in here, but no.
Like, uh, carrots.
No carrots.
So quiet all of a sudden.
Oh, hello?
I have three.
How many does it take to take him down?
I mean, definitely I will need more, though.
This place looks pretty...
Like, it's probably pretty secure.
With lots of men.
Huh?
What if...
I got the 24-carat gold Laboobu.
Would you say it for me?
I am the owner of the world's only 24-carat gold Laboobu.
Ah,
Dregos, thank you so much for the...
For the 20 gift and thank you!
Wait, what's in here?
Oh.
Just...
I thought it was carrots.
This place is quiet!
This place is too quiet.
It's quiet.
Too quiet.
Oh, I hear.
Where are you?
Oh, shoot!
No other ones, right?
Nice.
Um, I'm going to...
What's up, Doc?
I'll remember that these are here for future.
I'm exploring now.
Well, um...
But good thing we caught that before we were in mid-battle, no?
Okay, so we gotta disable this.
Actually, how do I...
Oh, I guess I just drive up here, huh?
We must disable.
Where?
just run up on them oh but you can shoot through these windows
yeah they just detonate rockets exactly make sense to me oh i thought somebody was behind
imagine the guy was it's the chair the cook chair someone to some guy just chilling in there
Okay.
What were they doing in here, huh?
You have to wonder.
I mean, you don't have to, but I do wonder.
I'm safe scumming, I'm safe scumming.
Oh, my golly goodness!
That's why I'm safe scumming.
Come here.
You come to me.
Yeah.
Wait, did I...
Did someone...
No?
Nothing?
What is this?
Oh.
Oh, my nose won't stop being so itchy.
Um, me too.
Um, what nose?
Um, me too?
Um, what news?
Nose?
This stupid VTuber thinks she has a nose.
Oh, screw that.
Come here.
No, no, no!
Oh shit!
Yeah, just fall off the edge.
Jump!
Yeah, like that!
Do that!
Oh my gosh, wait, they don't fall?
Wait, there's more?
Wait.
Oh, they can jump back up?
Oh!
Ah!
Wait.
I thought I heard a crawly sound.
Oh!
I hear a...
I don't think it was him, though.
The crawly sound that I heard.
Came from my left.
I know.
These guys are so stressful, no?
Oh, there's a door over there.
All right, there's so much around here, huh?
So even blowing...
Blowing them here did nothing.
Oh, I think I'm hearing, like, rocks crumbling.
Oh, okay, okay.
And stay down!
Oh.
Got a little.
All right.
One more building.
I think I got a little ahead of myself coming down here first.
I think we need to go over there to disable stuff.
But there was one other building.
I think where those guys came from.
This one right here.
But I want to check out real quick first.
Oh, it just leads me...
Oh.
Well, that works actually perfectly.
And then...
Ah!
Oh.
That's awesome.
Oh my gosh, wait though.
If you don't...
Oh, okay.
Also, this.
That, that, that.
But if you don't know that...
That, uh...
There's...
What's it called?
What was I saying?
Oh, if you don't know that there was that guy down there, you would just drop right on top of him.
That would be so evil.
that's what i was saying sorry my i got a little panicky because i came in here i was like where am i what's happening how do i get up there um what can i grab oh maybe you oops wrong button
i knew it was too quiet in here i knew it i knew it i knew it these guys are sick Oh, you can still see the old man's ear.
These guys are sick.
Sick and twisted.
Absolutely twisted.
Nice job.
Thank you.
I will save after that for sure.
For sure.
Okay.
There's a lot of ammo and stuff out here.
So I guess we go in there.
And I imagine when we come back to the spot is when we have to fight that thing again.
Hatsune Miku.
Paggy, Minto Paggy.
Paggy, Paggy.
Oh.
Don't like that.
Why would they be giving me so much supplies?
Okay, we'll be fighting him sooner than I imagined.
Okay, got it.
Oh.
Epic foreshadowing.
Yes.
Just in case there's regular men here.
Say first, I already did.
I'll save right here, actually.
This might be a better spot.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
get that guy out of the way I don't want to be thinking about him at all okay I see that ladder but I'm gonna go up first does that mean flammable
how did I notice I'm just good like that
gosh there's so much
so much supplies so so much supplies This is like big boss time.
Yeah, my glass is on.
It'd be funny if we could still see that little poison head crab downstairs.
Okay, let's go back down.
Big boss, like Metal Gear Solid.
Exactly, exactly.
Exactly.
Don't tell me to jump yet.
I'm exploring.
Jeez, Louise.
Can I...
Oh, wait.
Maybe from here?
Oh, my gosh.
Trapped on something.
I think.
Dual flip.
Maybe this side would be better.
Okay.
Nice.
We took out this.
this guy so we don't have to worry about him okay nice okay nice who's that that was dirty that was so dirty uh-oh uh-oh um there's a whole lot of shaking.
What's shaking, Bacon?
I didn't need to use that.
What is it?
Why is it shaking so much?
Uh-oh.
What's down there?
Oh, there's a train going on top of me.
Oh, cute.
So atmospheric.
Love this series.
Okay.
Is that a sniper?
They also, like, give you stuff if you drop.
This is so interesting.
I'm not sure what's going on at all.
Oh, that was so good.
If you drop, is a matter of when.
Okay.
Explosives down there.
Oh!
Whoa, whoa.
And another head crab.
Yep.
Oh no, it's a crossbow.
What is happening?
Why are they loading me up?
Ow!
Time for the crossbow.
If I could get out the door.
I thought I saw a guy go in there, but...
Allergic to rocket usage.
I got only three!
And I know I have a big guy coming up!
Maybe I should have used the rocket, so huh?
Wait.
We're fine!
Yeah, we're so fine.
Eww!
You can't reload this.
But I could reload everything else.
Let's see.
That's loaded.
Locked and loaded, baby.
What's actually?
45, okay.
Locked and loaded, baby.
Everything is locked and loaded!
Well, it was.
Uh, okay.
Onwards.
But where do I go?
Oh!
This area is so cool.
I'm paranoid as heck though.
I'm not gonna...
You!
I'm not gonna lie, I'm so paranoid in here.
I don't like it at all.
My ocean has no trigger discipline.
What do you mean?
Rip ammo.
I was full.
I couldn't take anymore.
Oh, the one that I accidentally shot?
Yeah, rip that ammo.
I think coming back is going to be hell, isn't it?
On the way here is nice and easy breezy, but on the way back is going to be hellscape, isn't it?
Is that what I'm deducing correctly?
Oh my goodness.
She's fine.
Am I?
I'm scared.
I don't feel fine.
Am I fine or am I fine?
She's fine.
Are we gaming?
Speed running?
Oh,
I hear somebody.
I hear some chatter.
Is that...
No, that's not where I came from, is it?
No way, did I take the longest way?
Oh my god, I see the head crab.
Oopsie!
Well, um, now we know.
We learn, we adapt, exactly.
I heard men.
What the heck was that?
That took longer than I wanted it to?
I guess I could have just run in and blasted.
Hello?
Woo!
You take hits!
Oh my goodness!
Oh!
You bastard!
I just used that health that I didn't mean to.
Oh, there's another one.
We're okay.
I do like that they eventually come to me.
Oh, sorry.
Why do you have red eyes?
Okay, we're fine.
Maybe.
Shotgunner.
Just like me.
We are twinning.
We are one and the same, baby.
I guess it would have been good.
I throw a grenade up here.
Everything explodes.
Would have been sick.
Would have been noise.
What did I just hit?
Oh, my nail.
Wait a second.
I got this guy.
If I can get out the door.
Is he up here?
Oh, wait.
I don't have...
Oh.
Elite sniper.
A sniper elite time?
Yes, absolutely.
Alright.
Let's go back to the shotgun.
Woo!
And...
I know there were three of you.
Just kidding.
I can't count.
They're so stupid.
Wait, um...
So then I gravity gun, right?
Uh-oh.
I don't like that.
I don't like that they're giving me everything.
It's a...
Did I complete it correctly?
Okay.
Are we puzzling?
Uh-oh.
I hear him.
Time to go.
Can I get him from here?
But I have nothing in here.
Oh gosh, okay.
I like how the...
This time I can actually shoot through the windows, right?
Who's shooting at me?
Oh, wait.
Is it him?
It felt like something else was also shooting at me.
Just don't hit the window.
Holy moly.
Oh, like there's actual guys shooting at me.
Yeah.
Holy cow.
Don't hit the window that detonates rockets.
I wish I could kill these guys, too.
These stinking guys.
Right?
Where are they?
Actually, I have no idea where they're coming from.
I have no ammo, yeah.
Time for me to go.
Wait, actually, let me read.
Below?
Under the bridge?
Oh,
I hear them.
Okay.
Oh!
I can also do that.
Did I get him?
I don't know.
Holy cow!
Okay.
We're going back down.
Under the bridge?
Oh yeah, I was about to be like, Oh, I can start shooting at him again.
Okay, okay.
Wait, can I go under the bridge?
Oh!
I'm... I didn't actually mean to grab that.
Okay, hold on.
Alright.
The head crab.
The head crab area.
That's where there was the unlimited ammo.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're running.
Oh, if I could.
Here.
Okay.
Alright.
No, it's the other side.
Ow!
It's over there!
Okay, okay, okay.
We gave in, we gave in, we gave in, we gave in, we gave in, we gave in, holy cow!
Maybe I'm being greedy.
I'm probably being greedy.
Ow!
Gosh!
This just sucks.
It's okay, I saved in here, so...
If I die, I die.
I don't care.
Were there...
Did I
ask him if they were...
Round two, anybody?
I might be the dumbest ghost ever alive.
I'm not alive, but I might be stupid!
I saved?
I'll save again?
I saved!
I can't even be mad about it.
You can't even be mad.
Okay, so now we just make our way...
Can I just jump?
And like, swim?
Let me try jumping.
Do I flip?
This is not Minecraft.
Okay.
Got it?
I understand now.
I don't think there was anything else I needed, so...
Oops, I missed.
Okay.
Doesn't mean you'll survive.
But Minecraft taught me if I fall into water, I'll be good.
Okay.
difficult than going down what if I jump now what if I jumped right now instead why is there why did they load me up with so much supplies when I really didn't need it do it okay wait let me save okay now I'll I'll live I'll live I'll
So some really good jumps over to the box.
Not that last few though.
Ouch.
It's okay.
My ankles.
Me ankles.
Nice.
Again, I think I got everything.
And around here.
Marlarg That was everything I needed to do, right?
I turned off the bridge.
I turned off the staff.
I'm not gonna get ambushed in here, am I?
Oh, oh gosh.
Okay, never mind.
We are.
Who will win?
Epic rap battles.
Crab head.
Head crab.
Or...
Oh, wait.
That means the sand.
That means the...
What are they called?
The sand lion- the ant lions are here.
Oh no.
That's no good.
Oh that's no good.
Okay uh, we're running.
I- for some reason I want to crawl- call them- oh!
Oh!
Anybody else?
Nice HP.
Always.
Oh my god.
Was there like some thumper I didn't know about?
Wait, but that gate is still on.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Maybe I go that way instead.
Okay.
Right.
Has to be.
Yeah.
Um, I feel like, hold on, one moment, please, there was health that I didn't need before that I can grab now.
I just don't remember where it all was.
Okay, not any...
Yeah, we'll drive across the bridge.
Of course, and we didn't totally hear all that rumbling before.
That would make it... You think anything is bad in there either, you know?
By the entrance and here?
Oh, there's one.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
There's some.
We can just top it off.
I lost all the little ammo for my suit that I had.
I- Oops.
Gosh, Gordon Freeman, you're fat ass.
You guys!
I don't want to fall.
fast anymore okay so i bought this i bought this skirt last year and i bought it i bought it in japan and um i tried it on in the store and it was already pretty tight when i bought it i was like i should size up and then the girl the like the the lady who was helping me she was just like oh my guys it looks so good on you you don't need another size you're fine blah blah blah and i was like okay um and i was i had full copium i was like yeah i'll be able to fit it no worries guys it's an extra small what was i thinking what was i thinking i tried putting it on today i could not get it up over my butt
and it was inexpensive it was so cute i was like i was like oh this is such a unique style of skirt and not only i'm just gonna tell you because i can't wear it anymore it's denim too so extra small denim what was i thinking and i i wore it once And I spent so much money on it.
Denim doesn't shrink.
I'm so sad.
I wanted to wear it so bad.
Oh.
Man.
Denim hella shrinks.
It does.
It shrinks in the wash.
so.
I'll buy the skirt.
Will you wear it?
It does?
Denim shrinks a lot?
But I don't think I ever dried it.
I think I always hung dried it.
I think my butt just got bigger.
I think my... I think my butt got bigger and now I can't wear those skirt.
We're getting the funny hat.
No!
Okay, I'm over it.
Anyway.
Let's go.
Over the bridge.
Okay.
I really thought we would be going through there.
Wait, there was also some supplies.
One moment.
I remember.
Slapping your...
Don't slap my ass!
Why would you do that?
No.
I'm so depressed about it.
I'm not going to lie.
Because the skirt was like, like I said, it was pretty unique.
The way that like, it's denim, but like, oh.
It was done.
So I don't go that way.
okay unless is there another thing i can gravity gun
okay wear your denim during showers i can't even put it on i can sense my oshi by listening for the clap of her ass no i'm gonna run off this bridge i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it wait can i get on this?
No?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I knew this was gonna happen.
Wait.
Goodbye, car!
It was, like, the slowest...
Oh!
What?
I didn't die!
Um...
Oops.
What am I supposed to do here?
Oh, I see it.
Oh!
No please I'm not gonna make it
Oops Oops Third time's a charm Wait, fourth time?
Respectfully slaps ass Don't slap my ass Please Gordon is the car Yeah We attach our
I can't slow down
I can't slow down We were so close Okay As soon as I get past
We made it Oh come on It's gotta be perfect He got my little This is the problem with having a fat ass He'll get it.
I am using Nitro.
I use it.
I do.
That's what you hear.
Like, this?
This is the Nitro.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm trying to get this denim skirt on, but I'm dummy thick.
What was I thinking?
Getting an extra small.
Oh, ah.
Oh my gosh.
This bit is pretty hard, actually.
At least it's...
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to...
I don't know if
the...
Swar!
You need to turbo all the way through?
I do?
Okay, okay, I'll try.
But I run out and I can't turbo.
Completely.
Oh my gosh!
I made it!
Save?
Ah!
Yeah!
Wait, why was I going so slow?
Why was I going so slow in the end?
That's funny.
Can I climb this?
No.
That'd be neat though.
First try, baby!
Every time you are sad about your enormous behind, just imagine Solid Snake telling you you've got a great butt.
Okay, I'll try.
But I can't wear cute clothes because my butt is too big.
Give me one second.
Okay, I was...
The reason I was turboing too late, or rather later, is because I was trying to...
Because you can only turbo for a certain amount of time, and then it's got, like, a recharge.
But whatever.
We got it to work.
Just got home of my mint merch from Gamersups.
Oh, thank you!
Thanks for ordering it.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Save, baby.
Let's go.
How do I get up there?
Oh, I don't need to get up there.
Let's go.
Wait.
One moment.
Is there anything down here?
Ouch.
Nothing.
My leg.
Uh.
Wait, did I make it?
Oh.
Ouch.
Uh.
Sure wish I had a flashlight in here.
Okay.
Uh.
Don't like that.
Wait.
I'm trapped.
This looks mighty familiar.
Like, it looks like when you're taking the train in Half-Life 1.
Why do I have...
Oh, I don't...
Wait.
I'm scared.
Why do I have my crowbar out?
I don't like it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, wait.
No, please, God.
Brave at home.
I don't want to go back to the spooky.
Wait.
No, no.
But these guys look like they're just sleeping.
Wait, God.
He's buggying.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
Come here.
Come here, you little cry baby.
Come here, cry baby.
I awoke the horde!
Oh gosh.
Oh, wait, I awoke the horde.
Oh my god, I awoke the horde.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, this is not good.
Wait, this is really not good.
Oh, God!
Ah!
Wait, my good doesn't work on them!
Oh, God!
Oh, oh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm trapped.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm running.
I'm leaving.
Please!
Stop beating me up!
Oh, there's so many!
Oh my god, you bastard!
Wait, where'd he go?
Is it never ending?
No, they end?
Okay.
Oh, okay, that's right.
There was health in there.
Maybe this is a mistake, but whatever.
We gotta get, we gotta, we gotta get these cars all...
Whoa.
Uh, we gotta get them out of the way.
Luckily the tunnel doesn't seem that big.
Right, guys!
$5 to help fund a new skirt.
Thank you.
Thanks, I actually went and bought a new one.
Why are you guys smiling?
Why are we smiling now?
Is there anything else up here?
I'll take this as ammo.
Because I mean, so cute.
Stop it.
Sook.
Okay, sorry, I keep saving.
I'm scared.
Wait, let me get out.
Let me change to...
Shotgun.
I love my shotgun.
Oh, okay.
And change out of the tunnel.
And out.
Yay!
Yay?
Looking at it is that you're thick like Snake.
Also just got my Game Recepts Cup.
Thank you!
Hopefully there's another with your new outfit.
Oh, maybe one day.
That'd be fun.
I can't move this guy.
I can move that guy.
Don't go on the sand.
Wow, though, this is...
Wait, why is your supplies over there?
Okay, good to know.
But I'll stick to the road for now.
Or the house.
Or...
We go off the road.
Those guys, the things will be in the sand, though, right?
Whoa, pirate ship!
What's that music?
What's the music for?
Speaking of booty.
They ever released new outfit?
Caller?
What?
Call?
Kira!
I don't know.
I have to release merch.
I have to release merch first.
I see more supplies over here.
I don't really need health, but...
More suit stuff would be great.
Nothing!
Just health, okay.
It's a cute collar.
You think so?
Would you wear it?
Would you guys wear it?
Yeah?
Oh, I see the guys.
I completely dodged them.
Whoops.
Yeah.
Should I go in there?
Do I need to go there?
If I meet the right person.
I'd wear it if you asked me to.
Yeah, why am I not the right person?
I think I got him.
Should I...
Wait, that place is on fire.
I saw him.
Wait, there's a graveyard!
How cute!
I remember spending an entire afternoon making a Gary's mod comic at this house.
We're having a barbecue!
Oh, I saw him.
Are you gonna come out?
How do I get in?
Wait, maybe I didn't see anybody.
Maybe I'm a liar.
Oh, that's how I get in.
Wait.
I'm scared.
If you want to have your next off-kai meet and greet include callers for all attendees, would fit in with the spitting too.
This we can discuss.
What am I doing here?
Oh, I'm just shooting these guys for funsies.
Big plans.
Okay.
We'll do that.
Sounds like a plan.
Sounds like a good idea.
Hello?
Who's in here?
Anybody?
Anyone?
Hello?
How are you?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Handled.
Oh!
Not handled!
There's still a guy over there.
But I don't think he'll bother us.
Unless we go out.
Sheesh!
Okay.
Ugh.
I just bolted from the...
I bolted from there.
I've never felt more...
more like of a...
of a re...
like I felt so sure about that in my whole afterlife.
Oh man!
I guess this is another place to get the crossbow if you haven't gotten it already.
Which is pretty nice.
Wee ball?
Effit, we ball...
Can I fall through?
No?
Okay.
Phew!
Alright, alright.
Good stuff.
I think that was worth going a little side trip.
That scared me!
Too thick to fall through!
It do be like that.
Savings to that.
I'm already in the car.
Does that reach?
Oh, it does.
You can charge the gun.
Whoa!
Nice, thank you.
I did not know that.
Come here.
Yeah, growling you all you want.
I hate these things.
I hate them.
Soop.
Come here, you too.
Yep.
Anyone else want a piece of me?
I go check it out.
I'm gonna go check it out.
Whoa, something exploded that hurt my ears.
Encouragement for upcoming Gundam card game tournament this weekend.
I'm having fun, but so far I'm 3-14, and so if I could win even just one game, I'd be super proud of myself.
Wait, what do you mean?
3-14!
That sounds like you won a couple, no?
No?
But you got this!
Good luck!
Have fun!
You got this!
If I can play this game, you can win.
I believe.
Hello?
I heard another guy.
100% I heard another guy.
I'm listening to his footsteps.
Another man?
We got him.
He dead.
Whoa!
What?
What a pattern.
That guy.
Oh, look at that!
That's kind of kind.
Wish they had one for my suit too.
Ho-key!
Ooh!
Cute!
Um...
Did I just go on through?
I guess so.
Can I, like, lift this?
No?
I just blast through it.
Let's just try blast it.
No, no, Grand Bathroom.
Riot!
Ram and speed.
Yep, we're gonna go full full power.
Oh, gosh.
Uh.
Okay, let's try that one more time.
Oh, wait, those lifted up.
Wait.
I could drive just fine, everybody.
Why is every place such an infrastructural mess?
Hmm,
I thought it would explode.
Sort of the apocalypse happened.
Yeah, but surely.
Where are my tax dollars going to?
This place seems kind of sus.
Cue the sussy music.
Oh, no, no!
Wait, those are different.
It looks like a... like a tarantula.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm getting ambushed.
How...
Throwing grenades at me!
Who else is she?
Oh, you.
I'm here.
Oh.
You could throw them back?
You could throw the grenades!
No way!
I didn't know that at all.
Quit being so grenadible.
It's just part of my time.
Hot dog and date.
Is this a trap or contraption?
Oh, someone had a bad day.
Combine gunships and dropships.
Wait.
Combine both mechanical and organic parts somewhat like geckos and MGR.
Oh.
Oh!
We got him.
Get souped.
I'm starting to get hungry.
That's what I'm getting.
But I had dinner before.
Before stream.
So I'm kind of like,
Okay, so we're trying to raise this.
Okay.
What did I have?
I had one slice of pizza.
Leftover pizza.
A couple days old.
Do I need to find more of them?
I suppose?
Oh, so like this.
Okay, now we just need to find one more.
Okay.
Um...
Does it look like a cinder block?
Hmm...
Or...
I can't tell if it's that I need to find one more.
We'll just do a quick little sweep.
And if not, maybe they have to be in like a...
Like...
What's the word?
Like, they need to be in a certain order.
My sweep?
I didn't see it.
Oh no, it definitely needs to be all three.
Can I climb
that?
What?
Aha!
Easy!
But, uh, how do I get around?
We're not leaving my car behind.
Slope?
Was there one?
Here?
Oh, I see.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah.
You're right.
Ah, cool.
Easy.
Unless your slice of pizza was at least a quarter pizza.
That's more of a snack.
No!
Oh.
Please, no more tunnel.
We're going through this tunnel.
We're not going to be in the tunnel.
We're going through the tunnel.
We won't be in the tunnel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow, it's so beautiful!
Is this the lighthouse place we need to get to?
Are we finally home?
That looks like a friend.
Yes!
Hey,
over here!
You made it!
We're picking up radio chatter.
They're looking for your car.
Put your car in the garage.
Oh.
You want me to...
I've done a lot of driving, sir.
If you could just back it up for me.
You know?
It would be really, really helpful.
Okay, I'll do my best.
Oh!
Get your car in the garage.
I did, sir.
Okay, Doc.
You'll have to go on foot from here.
There's a secret path along the cliffside, but no one's going anywhere until we fight off this attack.
Having you here to fight alongside us is going to make a big difference for morale.
Attack.
Crap.
Here come the dropships.
Uh-oh.
I didn't
even get to
Oh my gosh how did I miss I'm also ducking
What is happening?
Oh they're dropping men Oh my gosh Is there any more Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Drop ship, come- oh, drop- not drop ship, drop- drop ship.
Watch out friends!
Wait, that's not a good gun for this.
Don't mind me.
I'm just switching guns!
Grenade!
Oh!
I'm hurt.
Oh, that's a friend.
That's a friend.
My bad.
Don't mind me.
Oh, that's a friend.
Sorry, you guys are so confusing.
Uh, I dropped myself.
Nice, good job, team.
Um, do you guys have any, like, um, things?
Oh, thank you!
Ah, they're so sweet.
I didn't expect this to happen.
I thought I was gonna have a nice little...
Um, thanks for the dropship, or...
Am I...
Am I SOL?
Are we not fighting the dropship?
take this med kit thank you
oops he'll come around oh okay this is not good good for this one shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot what's in here I'm exploring nice hello team the lighthouse got it oh grenades okay cool cool cool thank you you too at the lighthouse can I throw from here whoo not far enough oh
my gosh where's my there it is
Take cover, everybody.
Oh, I'm out.
I can't shoot with this thing.
Maybe I can.
Gunship!
Oh, okay, thanks.
That's what I was asking about!
That's all I needed to hear!
Full of rockets, that's all I need to know!
Oh my gosh.
Don't die on me, everybody.
Where are all the rockets this place is full of?
Oh, upwards.
Oh, here they are.
Nope.
Yes?
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Ow!
noise
let's grab some more while we're here okay
I like the way it screams well I'm gonna go get more health
I will save actually more
oh no oh I'm I can't
What are these?
Saved.
Did anybody survive?
Oh!
This way, Dr. Freeman.
We'll take the cliff path before another gunship finds us.
Okay.
That one was easy because it...
Oh, sorry.
This is your stuff.
I'm just used to blasting everything.
Um, that one was easy because the lighthouse provided good protection.
Oh, pistol ammo.
Why would they give that?
Oh my gosh, more?
All right, Dr. Freeman.
Come with me.
Before another one comes.
Yep.
I'm right behind you, buddy.
Right along there.
And watch your step.
Right along where?
What am I?
Oh!
Whoa.
Oh.
Ouch!
Why, you could have warned me there were still guys.
Oh my gosh.
I'm running.
No, this is also just like the first game.
Where there was the gunship.
Uh.
Wait, they took my car?
No way!
Did the guy survive?
Missed the car being stolen.
Sorry, I was a little panicked.
Trying to just leave.
Wait, the baddies took my car!
It's me!
You there!
Stop!
You idiot!
Walking on the sand, bring down my ass!
He told me...
Dear God, poor Laszlo!
The finest mind of his generation!
an end we were heading for the vortigon camp hoping to pick up some bug baits of these damn things and leave us alone without Laszlo what's the point I know you tried to help I'll stay with him a while there's something I have to do go ahead I hope you have better luck than we had wait could I prevent this remember to stay off the sand the ant lions are edgy right now
Can I redo this?
Laszlo!
Here, I'm gonna reload.
Wait.
I'm guessing this is it.
Auto save.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's try it.
Okay, okay.
He's gonna tell me not to go out.
I would have listened to his full spiel, you know?
also sorry they talk so low but the game is pretty loud if the game is ever too low or anything just tell me you there stop where you are stay on the rocks okay don't step on the sand it makes the ant lions crazy lazlo don't move oh i
know it's pretty late in the stream to say that but poor lazlo the finest mind of his generation Oh, it's Laszlo's fault.
Hoping to pick up some bug baits of these damn things and leave us alone.
The finest mind of our generation.
What's the point?
I know you tried to help.
I'll stay with them a while.
I'm gonna eat some Reese's pieces.
There's something I have to do.
Go ahead.
I hope you have better luck than we had.
What's the point?
My ass is already big.
Oh, hot.
Remember to stay off the sand.
Okay.
The ant lions are edgy right now.
Oh, Bob.
It's
because I'm hungry.
You'll make it, right, buddy?
That supplies, though.
Uh, come on.
Yeah.
Can I get this too?
Oh, I can.
Come on.
Little baby?
What's that?
What's this?
Oh.
Whatever it is, I'm taking it.
Thin mints ain't got nothing on thick mints.
Find this ass of our generation.
Shut up.
Stop talking about my butt.
I'm insecure.
I know what for Oh, I'm full What are those
What is the alt on this thing
Well, that sucks SMG grenade Ah, okay, okay Oh, yeah, you're right I should be using this, huh?
Okay, uh, I saved And
Woo!
We're gaming?
Nice.
I'm cut.
I'm afraid you're going to have to stop talking about it first.
I wonder if I can, like, oh, I guess, let's try it alone.
I was going to say, like, if I could grab it and, like, move it.
But, of course, why do they respond to the stuff on the same?
and moving, but they don't respond to it.
Me on, like, or rather they respond to me on the sand, but not me moving things on the sand.
It's kind of funny.
Little inconsistent if you ask me.
In fact, I think that's exactly what I need to do here.
Ah, no, don't break, please.
Eh.
I'm heavier?
I'll leave you there.
Wait, can I make this?
Oh!
Because of the supply!
I was able to make it!
Ha ha ha ha.
Wait, uh...
Oh, did I have my SMG?
dang almost a perfect run almost perfect dang well there's still a lot left to go but you know what i mean it was almost great rip achievement no really wait i'm kind of curious okay you just die
i almost had it it's okay i didn't even know there was an achievement You guys should have never told me.
What do I hear?
What was that?
Hmm.
Chess out.
It's an annoying achievement.
Yeah.
I don't want the pressure, you know.
Love your new outfit!
Why does it give off Fujoshi vibes?
Why not?
I'm a...
You know?
Oh no, wait.
I see, I see.
This needs to tilt up.
Oh,
okay.
We got multiple places to go.
Fun.
Yeah, we're gaming.
Oh, look at all that support.
supplies over there.
Sweet, sweet supplies.
I don't really need it, but I want it anyway.
Oh.
No one in here?
Really?
Okay.
Wow, lots of stuff though.
I'll take it.
Oh!
You think I can still grab it?
Oops, that's not... that's not right.
Oh, nice!
We're fine.
Everything's good.
Wait, there's actually so much loot around here.
Wait, that makes me nervous.
But you have to work for it.
It's not just easy to get to loot.
So...
Yeah.
I just...
notice, how am I going to get back up there?
Hmm.
Um.
Okay.
Uh.
I wish I could...
One bad thing about this is you can't turn it.
Mom.
You guys don't call out to your mom when you're in trouble?
It's too short.
Yeah.
Okay, I made another thing for me to jump on.
Dama, thank you so much for the redirect.
Thank you.
Welcome, welcome.
Ouch.
That's fine.
I didn't need that.
physics physics are really scary oh my gosh how am I supposed to get out of here I think I'm supposed to run for
oh oh do I go thank you so much for the five gift and thank you a little bit of a there we go there we go okay okay
Oops, I jumped, but I didn't.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, ah!
Oh!
Why did you show up?
Where
did you guys come from?
Eh, whatever.
Please.
Please, soup.
We're souping?
No.
Nice.
I hit you?
Too far.
Wow, take that.
Good stuff.
Thumper.
A soup.
Try picking up a door or something else with a grab gun while standing on it.
Can you do that?
Wait, like this?
Ugh.
It didn't work.
That's a lot of exploding barrels over there.
Over yonder.
Alright, I run.
Oops.
Uh...
Am I supposed to make this jump?
Wait!
Oh my gosh.
I see.
Oops.
Come on!
The soup job.
What are these?
Are these for the SMG?
Pulse rifle.
Ah.
How do I get up?
Is there anything around?
Vivi-Court, thank you for the...
Gifted?
I know the area.
It is quite quiet.
I'll turn it up a little bit.
But sorry.
Actually, let me see if there's like a options audio.
Yeah, there's no like.
I've.
All shooty games should have a way to turn down the shooting audio.
They all should.
I apologize.
Can I pick this guy up?
No.
I'm getting souped.
I'm getting told soup.
Um...
Flash and make my free yogurt.
Oh wait!
There's these guys.
I don't know if this is the intended method, but...
Alas!
It is my method.
Can I...
Oh, I need another one.
Giving me fallout, too.
Giving me half-life, too.
I don't know.
I don't know how to stand it up.
You can't.
You can't turn things.
Yeah.
Pick it up and look it up.
Look at it.
Oh, like...
Oh, no!
Oh, it really is like that.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, can I crouch jump this thing?
Who said this wasn't gonna work?
Who doubted my genius?
I actually don't know at all what the intended way is supposed to be, so...
I'm actually...
I'm actually... I have no idea.
One bowl of mint soup, please.
Mmm, soup.
Come on.
No.
No, come on.
Yeah, you.
Okay.
Ew.
Oopsie.
Oh, you're fine.
You're fine.
Everything is okay.
Don't worry about it.
I was safe!
Yippee!
Wait, F6, there we go.
I don't know why.
Press something else there.
So this turns on...
The Thumper.
I keep turning down the volume.
Sorry, guys.
Dumpin, dumpin, dumpin, we're dumpin, dumpin.
Oh, baby.
Does she know what dumpers do?
I know that they stop it so that the things can't touch you.
The guys don't come to you.
Do they have another intended purpose?
Dumpin, dumpin, dumpin, dumpin.
We're dumpin, dumpin.
They dump.
We're dumping.
Oops.
Don't, don't, don't, no, no, no.
The couch.
Chair.
Do you think there's a few videos exploiting physics bugs?
You can fly, skip the whole buggy section, for instance.
Um.
Wait a second.
There's gotta be something in here.
No.
Oh.
Whoa.
Yeah, baby.
There's got to be something else.
It switches to my crowbar instead of my guns.
That's one way to get over here.
I guess.
No, what I was saying is when I go for my gravity gun sometimes to my regular guns, it goes to crowbar instead of the gun.
Maybe I was using the crowbar last and I just forgot to switch it back.
Might have been me.
I don't know.
Ugh.
Okay.
I want to make it over there.
I don't think I can.
Oh, maybe.
I won't be able to make it back up.
Okay.
Q to toggle the last use weapon.
Oh yeah, I forgot about that.
Thank you.
I forgot about Q.
I press G to go to the gravity gun.
I don't think you can...
Can you go to the gravity gun in other ways?
Oh, you can.
No, I always press G.
Yeah.
I like how people are like, yeah, you can press G and then also switch weapons with the numbers.
As if I'm not like so many hours into this game.
Though I did forget about Q.
I'll admit that.
Wait!
I can run to the thumper.
I completely forgot.
Stupid.
I did all this hard work to get the thumper working.
Wait.
Not that.
This one.
Oh.
Oh no.
Oh yes, yes, yes!
Yes!
Oh.
Where did you come from?
Wait.
Uh.
Does
that count as grass?
Or sand?
He's like, that's that's that.
And I have to blast your way through here.
Yeah, I definitely think that.
That is still sand.
That was kind of silly.
I'm trying to decide.
You know what?
Well, more are just going to come out, so whatever.
Oh!
They left me alone.
Oh my god.
So close.
Oh my god, it keeps going!
More!
There's more!
Do I just run through here?
There has to be that.
Bitch.
Go away.
I want the supplies.
Well, I have enough health, maybe.
What the?
Oh, my God.
Wait, what are you?
Oh, you're a boss.
Oh, gosh.
This is fucked up.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to use the explosives, but they're...
Ow!
They're far!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Hold on, come here.
And...
Oh, I was way too...
Way too close.
Oh my gosh.
What?
Oh, my friends!
My friends are here, too.
Uh, are they hitting me too?
I'm almost out of bullets.
Uh, let's try...
Not the crossbow.
Let's try...
Oh, wait.
I have, um...
Oops.
I'm out.
Wait, what about this guy?
Thank you.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh my god.
The freeman must follow.
Don't scare me like that.
Oh my...
The freeman will do wise to heed our expression of the Mermadog's aromatic pheropods.
The process is not entirely hygienic, therefore stand aside.
The freeman will have needs of these pheropods on the paths ahead.
Oh really?
Gather them now.
Okay.
Hold on.
One moment, please.
There's no more guys in here, right?
Good for now.
I saw one more.
By the door.
Yeah.
Oh.
Thank you.
Look at him.
go.
He's so cute.
Even though he scared the heck out of me.
Oh, I guess I really didn't, you know.
Hi.
Thank you.
Yeah, that was pretty freaky.
I didn't like it.
Nah, I don't care.
They're probably talking about how much they want, how much they want me, you know?
Good morning.
Oh, are you alright?
Freaky music in here, huh?
They're trash talking, man?
You know, they're trash talking me?
Then they're cowards.
They could just say it to my face.
Hey, my doctor, Freeman.
No prospect is just ahead.
One man alone wouldn't stand much chance going in there.
But a man with a pack of ant lines, well, that's a different story.
What do you mean by that?
Because of the thing I have.
Whoa.
I'm going to control them.
The Freeman honors us by his presence.
Follow Freeman.
I'm following?
The Freeman of the Force?
The free man will now be instructed in the use of pheromones.
Oh, I heard.
I learned to shepherd ant lions with the so-called bug bait.
The free man will now break out his venom pod and toss one into yonder pit.
The free man has done well.
Thank you.
End?
Oh, you're pushing me?
The free man can also coach his ant lions to attack specific targets.
Oh, it's like the things from before.
The little guys that I would throw.
The snarks, yes.
But do they turn on me now?
No, they don't.
They love me.
Come
here.
They love me.
They become your Pokemon.
to signal the outlines in your command to follow you come here baby shows his excellence in all things why don't you guys compliment me like that remember well what you have learned here the elite advance has greatest confidence in you thank you oh
Let's go, babies.
The streamer excels in all things.
They love me.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, so I just throw and I get to gather more.
Follow, follow.
The Minto has an exquisite storm.
Dangerous, make you smell.
Oh no, I gotta turn that off!
I can't go near...
Now the thumpers are not our friends.
You guys go right there.
What happens if they get close?
Uh-oh.
Priority warning.
Outlast stabilization force.
Six noble cross-task.
Perimeter restricted.
Disengage.
Okay.
Follow, friends.
Priority warning.
Perimeter restricted.
They just find it unpleasant.
Oh, okay, so I don't have to, like, keep them away from it, right?
Okay.
What a strange...
How did they discover that, like, that the thumpers worked like this?
You know?
I have a question, though.
If I stop holding this, will they turn on me?
Oh, they won't?
They still love me?
Oh, they still love me?
I need you, baby.
Holy cow.
Good job.
Wait.
Did we lose some?
Can I get more?
I love Ebers.
They respawn.
Let's go.
And they love me now.
What is this?
We did lose one!
No!
Uh, six, I have to remember this.
What they respawned, they do?
Bugs are infinite.
What's the bad side of using these guys then?
Oop!
I think we just lost our whole team.
It's kind of awesome.
And then if I queue, let's do a queue as a...
We'll do our, whoops, a shotgun.
And then, shotgun.
Where, okay.
Just wanted to make sure that I had it.
All good.
I didn't even notice that that was a thing.
Okay, cool.
I don't know what I just shut off, but.
Yeah!
Oh.
Where?
How, who dares shoot?
Descend my army!
Okay.
Where are they shooting at?
Where'd they come from?
Hmm.
Are you okay, my babies?
We're okay, babies?
Doesn't matter.
They're dead now.
Yeah, pretty much.
I don't know what I turned off in there, but...
It's okay.
Shh.
I will.
protect you.
My babies.
It can be off of this thing!
How much more of this chapter do I have?
Ah!
Mother.
A bit?
Okay.
wait did we start a new chapter let's
run for it oh wait we can't get up there I think oh my gosh oh my god oh my babies go that's not fair how do you have that ability oh wait that's not what I meant right no no oh my gosh I messed it all up
Stop!
Can I even get this going?
I'm confused.
I don't think the grenade...
Will the grenade work, actually?
Uh...
It bounces off.
What's this over here?
Hold on.
I might die again.
I'm about to die.
Eh?
Go my children!
Oh, we lost one.
It's so sad to see.
Oh!
Go my children, go!
Ouch.
Who keeps sending those?
I don't even see when they throw them at me.
Oh my god, finally.
Okay.
Run to the next rock!
Uh, babies, this is not looking so good.
Oh my god, he's drowning!
It was fun just on my...
Oh, my bad face!
Run!
Somewhere!
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Why would you throw that?
You stupid!
I really need to use my gun, but it's hard to switch between.
Come, my bad boys, come!
Come to me!
I'm here!
Yes.
Um...
There's a lot going on over here.
I'm gonna save.
Oh, that probably wasn't smart.
You know what?
That's fine.
Because I have low health.
But that's okay.
Uh...
What if I...
I don't know, that didn't reach though.
No!
My babies!
I have no idea.
It's really messed up that they are able to...
to shoot me from below.
This isn't the way!
Uh oh.
Where am I supposed to go then?
And why is that guy just shooting non-stop?
Is he bugged?
Oh, I see!
Up there!
I see up there, I see.
Okay.
I'm waiting for my power to...
Yeah!
There we go.
Good job, babies.
Payback.
All right.
We're back in business.
Thank you guys for letting me know that that was not the right one.
I like babies.
A little pit.
Oh, we revel in the pit.
Why are you throwing flares?
Oh no, it's this thing again.
I forgot these things existed.
But now you have a gravity gun.
So true.
Hello, babies.
I need to get through.
Sort of block.
Oh
my god, I'm sorry, baby!
My burpers!
Good job, babies.
Good job.
Oh my gosh.
More babies.
I mean, more people.
I wish I had more babies.
Actually, why am I using this gun?
Sorry.
That would be, like, closer to them.
Use the anti-liance to kill 50 enemies, nice.
Did I hit you on accident?
I'm sorry, baby.
One moment, babies.
I love all my children.
Equally.
Explosives.
Be careful.
Be careful, babies.
Oh, what's in here?
One moment.
Oh, if I go in here, I can't get out.
Okay, yeah.
It's like, wait a second.
Oh my gosh, another place to get the crossbow?
Okay.
Good job, babies.
Oh my god!
These are Mike Tyson's ass.
Thank you so much for the redirect.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
400.
Actually, I wonder...
Crossbow.
Oh!
Oh, you have...
I don't know.
Oh, you scared me, babies.
Look at you guys!
do such a good job i'm gonna miss that knot when they when they all eventually die you know
no no pregnant wisps i want these babies i want ant lion babies are you guys ant lions is that what you're saying huh
What's this?
Ear protection.
That's smart.
Look how they purr!
They're so cute!
I'm obsessed with them now.
This prison's crazy.
Oh, okay.
Oops.
I'm insane.
Oh, damn.
That was way too... Actually, Let's go with...
You.
Go, my babies!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, you.
Woo!
Can I use this to destroy...
Not just them, but also the...
The plane.
Um...
Where'd the plane go?
Just kidding.
Wasn't that important.
Okay.
Dropship.
Technically, yes.
That'd be crazy.
Hold on, I'm picking up supplies.
I don't remember where I killed anybody, though.
Aha!
Very good.
Oh, oh my gosh.
There's so many.
weapons now it's hard for me to keep track of all the of all the numbers at this point that's why i'm always flipping through them because i'm like oh which one was who is who is
who's the ghost that's got the stream that's made for you and me oh m-i-n-k-m-y-t-o-a oh wait wait Thank you.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I didn't make it.
What letter?
I was trying...
Wait, where am I?
I was trying to spell ghost.
Oh, wait a second.
There's a ladder there.
Gamers don't look up.
But then over here...
There is.
Oh, wait, I can go from here.
Yes.
Oh, no, I was gonna say some...
Uh-oh.
I was gonna say there's friends, but there's definitely not.
Oh, I could have set them on fire, but whatever.
Everyone made it, right?
Why are there only two of you?
Where are your brothers and sisters?
Oh, shoot.
There's nothing here.
Oh, yes, there is.
Lift me up, babies.
Raise me up.
Babies?
Babies.
Raise me up.
Dang.
It's a gravity gun puzzle.
It looks like the alien they found in...
in, uh...
In Mexico.
The crowbar.
What do I need the crowbar here for?
My babies are burning?
That's not what's happening, is it?
Look, he's just warm in his bum by the fire.
Puzzle time.
Hmm, swoop.
Do I make a, like a...
What's it called with this?
Move, please.
Mommy's working.
Ouch!
Oh, wait a second.
We got it.
Um...
Where could they be?
Dropped wood on the baby.
They didn't mind.
Oh.
Where are you?
There you are.
I got him.
We got him.
I'm almost out of...
This is purring.
Almost out of ammo for this thing, Norm.
Sad.
We'll just switch to the regular SMG.
And look at that.
We're back here.
Take their stuff.
Oh, look at you, smart guy.
Nice!
Oh, there's more over here.
Where are you guys going?
Wait, can I go over there?
Oh, here guys.
Uh...
Nah, they're like, we found you, help mom!
Ha!
Yes.
Brrrr.
What's happening?
What?
What was that noise?
Oh my gosh.
They're so loud sometimes.
They're going?
They are...
Oh!
Hello baby.
Do I need to go in here or...
Let's retreat real quick.
They started going after my guys so fast I didn't even notice.
That guy's dead.
Um...
Because the Minto is excellent in all things, she will surely notice if she hasn't, the Gravity Gun's little arms will open when aiming at things you can pick up.
Yeah, I know that.
It also makes a sound.
I think...
Sometimes you guys think I'm really dumb.
Can't tell... Oh, that guy's definitely...
One down!
Oh, there he is.
Wait.
So able to get in between the cracks.
This guy's really freaking out though.
I can't tell where it's...
It's like...
Ah, there we go.
Easy.
Take care of them before we even have to worry about them.
Any more head crabs in here?
Oh, hold on.
She knows.
Yeah, this is a good save spot, you're right.
I probably should do like a hard save instead of like a...
You know.
Are we in the prison?
Oh.
Freaky zombie.
I hear them.
Where are my babies at?
I lost them.
You're in the entrance.
Maybe then we call it here.
Courtyard.
Oh, there's a ladder.
I took out the light!
And him at the same time!
Some other guy took over, though.
So sad.
I wish I could snipe.
I wish I could snipe always.
Oops.
Oh my god!
The force at which these hit them is crazy.
Maybe we call it.
Oh yes, yeah, I got those guys.
And then...
Damn.
Is this a sneaking mission?
No.
Okay.
Not anymore.
Where are they hitting me from?
Oh my gosh.
Can I get up there?
Can I get up here?
That'd be kind of cool.
Do they...
How do they eat?
Good thing you still have your bug friends.
Where are they?
Oh!
They're coming.
Hello, one bug friend.
And two bug friends.
My bug babies.
I'm gonna name you Barry Bug.
And Barrent Bug.
Okay.
For real.
I should save.
I should.
I save.
We're fine.
Okay.
Do they know Barry?
No, how bugs know each other?
No.
I mean, she might, though.
Who am I to say?
Sorry, I'm having so much fun.
I don't want to stop, but I need to.
I need to stop.
Okay, I'm having so much fun, though.
Okay, I need to stop.
I need...
I put the...
I'm...
Hands off!
Hands off the controller.
Hands...
I'm not controller.
The keyboard.
Hands off.
Hands off, hands off.
Okay.
What are we at now?
Load.
Sand traps.
We're still at sand traps.
I thought we would get to a new chapter, but...
Not quite, I suppose.
Ah!
This was fun!
I didn't expect to go for so long, to be honest.
But I couldn't stop.
I couldn't stop playing.
I had so much fun.
Logan, thank you so much for the vibe gifted.
I will be gone for the next couple of days.
Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
Maybe Monday.
I will see how I feel once I'm home.
So maybe the next four days.
but if i see you at the mgs con i will see you um if not have a good weekend yeah i was having a crummy night but you really helped turn it around thanks sam i'm sorry you're having a crummy night i'm glad i can help a little bit virulent thank you have fun when delta comes out super robot wars comes out the same time so i'll be playing that all day okay i will have fun with delta then do i go thank you for the prank thank you thank you thank you Proper nutrition.
I will eat.
No worries.
Safe travels, boss.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Keeps the watching video keeps the existential dread at bay.
No, don't have existential dread.
I will be playing Delta next week.
Tuesday.
Tuesday, Tuesday.
All day, Tuesday.
So if you want something to have on in the background all day long, baby, I'm your gal.
Oh, thank you so much for the 20 years.
Thank you!
Good luck at MGSCon.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Excited to see you open for MGSCon.
Yeah!
Thank you.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay!
Um, then, I'll see you guys.
Otominto.
Have a good day, have a good night.
Have a good time zone.
And I will see you later!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Wait.
Before I go throw away the card.
crowbar.
There we go.
One full size.
Full body.
I never do like with other hair.
With this outfit yet.
Stummy?
Okay.
Wine stummy for the road.
Bye bye.
See you in a few days.
Or if I see you this weekend.
See you this weekend.
But if not, see you.
See you in a few days!
Bye bye!